MAN: It's impossible
to understand
Bin Laden without reference
to his religious beliefs.
This was a guy who,
when he was a teenager,
was praying seven times a
day, fasting twice a week.
On the other hand, he
was also a mass murderer.
What was his
relationship to religion?
[music playing]
Given how religious
Bin Laden saw himself,
it's not a surprise there's
a lot of religious material
on these drives.
How great is our last
panel, [inaudible]..
[non-english singing]
MAN: He would
often recite verses
from the Quran in his letters.
He would refer to sayings
of the prophet Muhammad
in his speeches.
He thinks he's religious.
He thinks he was
doing the right thing.
But he was not a
religious authority.
He was not a graduate
of a seminary
or any kind of traditional
religious training.
And so we have someone who's
a non-specialist making
unorthodox interpretations
of the faith,
because he actually starts
by acknowledging that Islam
prohibits the killing of
noncombatants in warfare,
but then goes on to
explain, in his mind,
why the political situation
that we are living in
allows him to violate that rule.
What he did was to use
political justifications
to violate a religious edict.
[non-english singing]
MAN: This homemade video
found on the hard drives
begins, as many of these
al-Qaeda videos do,
by quoting a religious verse
with chanting in tandem,
and then the message
becomes clearer.
We hit the United States,
and we scared them.
Then inevitably, Bin
Laden himself speaks,
preaching to his followers.
And I think it's a really
telling piece of propaganda,
how it weaves together
religious imagery
to superimpose
them on the tactics
and actions of al-Qaeda.
This homemade
propaganda was crude.
But tragically, it
was also effective.
He was using
religion as a tool.
[non-english singing]
It's a means to control
people, to make people do
whatever you want them to do.
And the ends justify the
means, like any psychopath
can justify anything.
I mean, at one point, he
actually told his commanders,
don't shy away from
shedding blood.
You know, if you
look at the crusade,
do you think Christianity
is a crusade?
No.
The same thing-- it's
people using religion
to obtain political goals.
I think it's
tragic that we let
a criminal define the religion
of 1.8 billion people.
We would never take the word of
the KKK to define Christianity.
It would be ludicrous.
It would be offensive.
If the Quran is a
recipe book and it
called for a tablespoon
of sugar in the recipe,
and extremists would read
that and put a cup of sugar
instead--
so taking what the Quran says
and taking it to its extreme.
Bin Laden didn't do that.
He read in the Quran, you
need a tablespoon of sugar.
And instead, he put
a cup of cyanide.
That's not an extremist.
That's a deviant revisionist.
Bin Laden's view of
his religion and violence
extended to his own family.
Terrorism was the
family calling,
and he was willing to sacrifice
even those closest to him
for his self-styled holy war.
[non-english speech]